[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
mark silverman is the co-host of sylvian
waddle the very popular
espn 1000 radio show in chicago
and sylvie joining us on the program
when did you realize that what you were
going to talk about on monday
was going to change after the interview
with scottie pippen
right after your interview is done uh
you know we obviously were on this as
you
joked yesterday dan uh this is a gift
to chicago sports radio and so we thank
you for that personally
friday we were all over it too and
the joke waddle has always said to me
you know he's the former bear
he he's lived here forever so he's a
chicagoan
but he doesn't get what we get for me as
a sports fan and then i covered the last
three bowls championships as a reporter
young
reporter down the dial um
that i always get worked up about scotty
that a lot of the times i've defended
scotty
i have fought for years on espn 1000
about scotty getting his due then scotty
not being just a top 50 player but being
a top 30 player scotty being a
revolutionary player
and then now all of a sudden i felt like
a scorned
lover and i really it's really broken my
heart
uh regarding all the bitterness that he
has shown and your interview just took
it
to this whole new level that gq couldn't
go
especially with the way he was talking
to you but he believes what he's saying
but nobody believes him right
right and it's kind of like a buddy dan
we all have them
we all know him that he says oh
this person in my life sucks this person
in my life is not loyal
this person in my life isn't good for
business
well maybe if you've got all these
people who are bad maybe it's you
maybe you need to look in the mirror and
i've always found it interesting we know
he hated krauss
hated krause they didn't love jerry
reinsdorf
as the owner and he was the guy who
signed the checks
but we always thought they had a bond
with michael and scotty and phil and
that they
they were loyal together even if it was
just with a common denominator of
disliking management
but now scotty thinks that michael's
selfish
and that phil was a racist who's left
standing
and maybe it's scotty that's the issue
here
and i think it's sad i really like he he
wants to sell bourbon and he wants to
sell
books but i just don't think that's a
reason to go
and ruin the relationships of one of the
greatest teams of all time
yeah i was just trying to understand the
logic of all of this and i couldn't help
but go back to april last april sylvie
and if that documentary doesn't come out
is scottie pippen saying what he's
saying
this week it's funny because uh we had a
we had a great relationship with jason
hare
the director and i know he reached out
to waddle yesterday
they they knew each other from bc jason
the director was a
bc ball boy so he knew waddle when he
was a player
and i think he felt a little guilty at
the way scotty came across
and my whole rationale has been the
documentary didn't make scotty look that
way
scotty made himself look that way just
like scottie made himself look that way
yesterday there are so many great things
in scotty pippen's career and i think
unlike others from the 90s dan where you
see this new way of playing basketball
i think the appreciation has grown for
scotty through the years
that we realized wow this guy was the
first
this guy is exactly the way the modern
day basketball player was
but you know the i think it's just an
excuse going back to the documentary
and and this whole notion that michael
commissioned it and michael got the
documentary he wanted
i'm a michael fan i covered michael i
think after watching all the episodes
we come away saying boy michael was kind
of a bully
michael could have been a big jerk
michael a lot of times was in it for
michael
we still look at him highly but i don't
think that the
the documentary was a fluff piece to
michael jordan
what was your show like yesterday with
uh local reaction
you know it's it's full phones um
everyone wants to talk about it you know
we have we have a hot baseball in town
the socks are good
the cubs are good we got adjusted fields
finally
maybe you'll have me on to talk about a
quarterback that's good finally in
chicago
um but but yeah i mean this is
in like i reached out to wilbon
yesterday because i think he feels like
me
and he said obviously being in phoenix
it doesn't resonate in phoenix but in
chicago
just like a year ago dan when we're
sitting in the pandemic
and we're rehashing arguments that are
22 years old or
25 years old we're doing the same thing
a year later in 2021 it's amazing and
it's sad
i mean again like the 85 bears buddy
ryan and mike ditka hated each other
and now maybe we're finding out that one
of the greatest all-time american sports
teams
all hated each other but you're messing
with a brand
that's what scotty's doing you're you're
you're messing with a scrapbook for
people
and i think that's what probably bothers
fans is no
we choose to remember this team these
moments like this
you don't you don't you know don't
disrupt this
you know now all of a sudden we're
looking and you know michael is
orchestrating steve kerr's last second
shot against utah and phil wanted tony
in there because he's white to take the
shot
and that that's that's a lot
that's a lot to unpack it it's a lot to
unpack
and i couldn't believe like the the phil
stuff
and they fought for phil all they did
was fight for phil
and now 20 plus years later you're
coming out
but the ker stuff dan the curse stuff
i don't understand how you orchestrate
something
all that is is game planning you know
what orchestrating a play whether it's
for the cameras or not
you orchestrated a way to clinch a
championship
by finding steve kerr for the open shot
so
it wasn't about making michael look good
it was about winning that fifth title at
that time
and setting steve kerr up for the best
shot whether or not
you know he was playing to the cameras a
little bit more look we all know
athletes
they even say it when they get mic'd up
sometimes
miced up athletes are a little more
outgoing or we'll play to the cameras
brady's done it
uh russell wilson's done it maybe he was
playing it up a little bit more
but what did it lead to it led to a
championship clinching
shot that wasn't his and i don't know
why scotty could ever
argue with that did anybody have a
problem with john paxton taking a shot
against the phoenix suns i mean i
now i go back and i start to do
inventory here like uh wait who took the
last shot
oh john paxton he's white i i like
i mean crazy it's crazy and and dan
there's like to the point about the
documentary and
whether it was orchestrated there's a
very famous moment from the bulls
championship
91 video the first championship against
the lakers
i'm a nerd like this i watched this
video like 100 times in college
and phil turns to michael in the fourth
quarter
he goes michael who's open and michael
didn't answer then he repeated himself
michael who's open he goes pax
and he goes give the ball to pax and pax
ended up scoring 10 or 12 points
in the fourth quarter to clinch game
five they win their first championship
so
you know i'm all for orchestrating
championships i think we could all use
more of those how's your quarterback
situation there sylvie
um i love it finally i think i maybe
have a quarterback
that we can we can all love together
like cutler
pippen is similar to cutler they're vul
they're both as polarizing as they come
so jay if you go in chicago and you ask
a hundred people
did you love cutler did you hate cutler
you're gonna get a 50 50 split another
one of these sports radio things
that if we open up the phone lines would
go crazy
the only problem i have with matt maggie
is
he's not giving the opportunity of
justin fields to win the job
i didn't like that he said no justin
fields has no chance i get it it's hard
and maybe he can't win the job right
away and that andy dalton is better
from the start but give the kid a chance
to win and i think you're limiting
yourself by saying
he can't win the job glad you're uh
doing better uh
my best to waddle there and uh thanks
for joining us
you got it dan thanks for having me
appreciate you and you're welcome for
yesterday
thank you again we've always appreciated
it
the gift yes that's uh mark silverman
sylvie and waddle
espn 1000